answer me quickly autonomously should
you picture that you with yourself at
the center
I don't know
do you know what you must do
but I do and I will teach you
each time to come out of the basement
foreign
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that encourages you to
know
and if the choppy black and white
animations have include you in yet yep
we're in that part of YouTube again that
shadowy corner where anything goes where
you'll see things that burn themselves
into your mind that corner that you
probably shouldn't be watching at 3am
but you're gonna try to anyway to see if
you're brave enough to last and then
you're gonna pass it on to your friends
as a humble brag saying look I watched
this can you the horror in question
today is a small Indie channel that I've
had my eye on for a while now called
underscore boazvert or as I believe it's
actually pronounced lavair when I see
the underscore at the beginning it
always makes me think that there needs
to be a dramatic pause there like Bluff
hair anyway blavare is French and
literally translates to green wood which
I don't think has anything to do with
the Twisted images that you're about to
be seeing in its videos the phrase is
also used in a French figure of speech
un vole de boaver which means a barrage
of criticism likely more why it was
chosen for the series and not the whole
Greenwood thing regardless I'd like to
take this opportunity to offer a formal
apology to the entire entirety of the
French language for this video anyway
brother is a peculiar little Channel
with imagery and sound design that's
equal parts creative creepy and cryptic
the videos are almost avant-garde in
their use of visuals combining a lot of
different animation and filmmaking
techniques into something that's truly
uncanny and often terrifying seriously
from the very first video we jumped from
traditional sequentially drawn animation
to skin crawling live action with heavy
filters and rotoscoped visuals
oh my God
and that's just what's on the surface of
the very first video look a little
deeper and you start finding allusions
to biblical stories horrifying monsters
and heightened almost academic language
there's also a lot of imagery in there
of floating hands trying to give us the
tickles so that's fun if you can manage
to Brave your way through its uploads
it's clear that there's a story here but
the timeline of events is completely out
of order there are also elements of an
ARG here like Morse code and QR codes
that are linking to unlisted videos and
you know me when I see an analog horror
series with ARG elements can't help but
get to the bottom of it there is clearly
a deeper story hidden in this channel
just under the surface and what I found
at the end of the mystery was not at all
what I would have expected guava is
simultaneously one of the darkest and
twisted Explorations in the human
emotion that I've seen and yet once you
understand what you're watching it hits
hard it is real it connects in a way
that most other media doesn't and to top
it all off it's uplifting don't let this
fool you friends this story has itself a
happy ending that said before it gets
there boisver is heavy friends consider
this your content warning today we're
braving our way through topics like
depression anxiety isolation and
self-harm but I promise you it all comes
out good in the end so what is the
creator of boisver trying to say through
all the unsettling Whispers
very first video take care it's clear
that we're diving into a plot that has a
lot to say here we meet our main
character and artist I'm gonna call him
antlers guy because none of the
characters in the series appear to have
official names antlers guy counts the
small victories where he can including
waking up at a reasonable hour
consistently exercising ignoring the
noises downstairs yeah you can kind of
see where this one might be headed
before too long antler's guy is drawn to
the noises heading down into the
basement and it's there that we meet our
main monster room a shadowy figure with
a disturbing triangular head suddenly in
a jarring twist the art style shifts to
live footage with the entity charging at
the camera Whispering a series appointed
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see your friends
it is creepy stuff but the questions
that room asks us give us our first clue
as to what the series is about based on
the video's upload date May 2020 and the
very first words that we see on screen
these are troubling times my friend we
know that Boise is exploring the
feelings of isolation that were brought
upon by the covid lockdowns basically
this thing is like Bo Burnham's inside
without the musical numbers and
Instagram jokes antler's guy is clearly
having difficulty adjusting to the
isolation and this triangular-headed
figure in the basement represents the
depression that lurks within the depths
of his mind but this isn't the first
time that he's had to deal with room or
the depression that he represents in a
later video entitled entirely beloved we
hear that antlers guy has always
struggled with Bridging the chasm and
drawing near without reprisal AKA
connecting with other people and though
he's actively tried to seek out
relationships he's never been able to
find them but it is to no avail I am in
love alive we also see this play out in
another video they don't know here
antlers guy is consumed by the dark
figure while attending a party before
the lockdowns happen clearly no one
understands his distress he begins to
flail around wildly and no one responds
to it interestingly this video is also
based on the they don't know Meme which
also had an earlier Incarnation with the
caption I wish I was at home a phrase
that makes me want to say be careful
what you wish for friends but that was
before now that antlers guy has been
quarantining at home the depressive
thoughts are seeping into every other
part of his life most obviously his work
we see that same shadowy creature
appearing as a drawing while antler guy
tries to remain productive in lockdown
and that's not the only moment it
happens while scrolling through the
video frame by frame if you pause it at
the perfect moment you'll see room
peeking in at antler's guide through the
window this whole idea of your house
your room a once safe place now becoming
an oppressive prison is a major through
line for boisvere's thematic narrative
in a later video Prelude Angels warning
there's a series of dots and dashes down
in the description seasoned air jeers
will immediately recognize this as Morse
code and when you run it through a
translator it asks when does a home home
become a complex that phrase is also
included in a secret message in the same
video hidden in the closed captions
during some heavy breathing
either way that question when does a
home become a complex has a double
meaning for the series both as a
physical Prison Complex as well as a
psychological Mental Health Complex
antler's guy clearly feels trapped not
only in his home but within the confines
of his own mind but when the prison
finally opens its doors when the world
becomes safer and he's able to get out
again things just get worse the damage
has already been done antler's guy is
still terrified of going outside but now
he has the added layers of guilt and
otherness to contend with as the world
moves on without him we see this in the
video burning.mp4 released in March of
2021 burning states that an entire year
has passed since the world was shut down
and our protagonist is not doing well
his expression is now permanently veiled
in Shadow instead of waking up in
Courage he views his life as just a
series of endless cycles that continue
to repeat he lives paralyzed in the
basement watching the rest of society
through the window now all he can do is
stare at a blank sheet of paper and Bash
his head into the desk until he's fully
consumed by his inner Darkness
thankfully antler's guy isn't completely
without hope next upload continue
dramatizes his internal battle as a
video game showdown between two new
figures skull face and dog face again
because they don't have official names
we're just gonna call these characters
pessimism and optimism respectively and
let me tell you this video has got
pretty much everything you'd want in a
good Showdown a hero a villain a music
track that absolutely slaps
pessimism looms large over a game over
screen an antler's guy has to
contemplate quitting notice that the
default option on the screen is actually
quit however even when antlers guy
chooses to continue pessimism replaces
the option for a split second as not a
chance encapsulating the hopelessness
that's consumed antler's guy we actually
see literal manifestations of those
thoughts scrolling by in the text above
and below pessimism goes pretty fast but
if you pause on certain frames you can
see phrases like I've always deluded
myself I will end you today in every
subsequent day you will have no hope I
suspect that these are his inner
monologue the negative things that he's
telling himself as he spirals further
and further downward thankfully optimism
appears representing an option to
continue battling and ultimately
stabbing pessimism antlers guy will
continue for another day in its final
moment pessimism even Sprouts dog ears
representing how pessimism can be
reshaped into optimism if you just give
it the chance interestingly I believe
that optimism in the story is
represented by a dog-faced creature
because there is a massive spike in pet
adoption during the pandemic with one in
five American households adopting either
a cat or a dog for many these furry
companions served as a ray of sunshine
that brought much needed positivity and
optimism to people at the height of
kovid's nasty strain of isolation in a
later video we do see a dog Avatar
representing optimism so it does seem to
track but has anyone struggling with
depression knows it's not about winning
just one battle this isn't the sort of
diagnosis where you have a single moment
and suddenly you've conquered depression
handling depression is a process that
takes time and we see that happening in
the next series of uploads to complex
and entirely beloved pessimism returns
in a new much darker form called the
complex
the complex has driven antler's guy to
push everyone away and so doing he's
trapped him in a new prison one entirely
self-made forcing him to sit alone in
Silence with all these dark thoughts
just spiraling because he feels as if
he's missing something antler's guy
draws even further in from everyone
around him on a community post from the
channel we actually see this reiterated
it says something is missing with a hex
code that leads to this image of a chair
and a QR code leading to antler's guy
sitting on it alone forever in a dark
room all of this causes antler's guy to
be entirely consumed by his dark room
Persona sent not just to the basement
but into a deep well in the basement
lower than low the literal abyss of
Despair it's there that he comes to a
disturbing conclusion though he always
wanted genuine connections with other
people he simply couldn't bring himself
to take that chance because he was
afraid he explains and when you come
here you will see in my eyes here but
it's not just that he's afraid of other
people he's afraid of not being loved I
say this because the video ends on the
French word for fear but the closed
caption subtitles actually replace the
word fear with love in fact the complex
actually spells it out for us for a
brief moment in the video consequences a
QRC code appears in the corner and once
this thing's scanned it takes you to a
secret unlisted video here the complex
explains that love is not a guarantee in
anyone
life without ever feeling love it would
be an entirely alien concept to them
even when consumed by the room entity
antlers guy still wants to feel the
warmth of love and his depression has
left him so emotionally drained that
even the concept of love feels foreign
to him all of this becomes too much for
antler's guy in the final shot of
entirely beloved room looks up and we
see that his mask the only thing that
allowed him to face the world has
shattered we see the Fallout of this
throughout the rest of the video
consequences the once calm and clean
space that antlers guy lived in is now
wild and chaotic the home has become a
true reflection of the distress that he
feels within and with this we arrive at
the climax of the story arc zoning
ordinance even the title's a hint at
what we're about to see zoning
ordinances dictate how a specific
property is meant to be used since the
state of antler's guy's dwelling space
represents his mental state this video
will decide which mindset will govern
him will he give in to his dark thoughts
or will he defeat them and move forward
antlers guys consumed by a shadow form
sitting at the bottom of a deep pit in
the basement while complex looms over
him that's when the injury optimism
arrives bloodied but not beaten in fact
it literally drags the corpse of
pessimism with him as it arrives at the
pit immediately the complex lashes out
and attacks optimism trying to drown out
its positive intentions this then starts
another battle and another killer beat
[Music]
during the struggle pessimism's corpse
is knocked into the pit an antlers guy
begins to devour it symbolic of how in
his depressive State he's literally
feeding on negative thoughts and during
this epic struggle of positivity versus
negativity optimism against pessimism
hope versus depression antler's guy is
wounded as a knife falls into the pit
and Strikes him I think this is
blavare's way of portraying the topic of
self-harm but in this moment he
encounters the angel which uh not really
the thing that I want to see while I'm
approaching the Pearly Gates gotta say
then again some angels in the Bible are
described as interlocking golden Wheels
covered in eyeballs so you know maybe
this thing is more accurate than I'd
care to admit regardless the angel
Comforts antlers guy asking him to
re-center his thoughts on himself
picturing himself as the center of an
empty room it encourages him to cry out
so that no one can ignore him telling
antlers guy that it's okay to ask for
help antler's guy reaches out to the
angel pulling off its face and then
putting it on himself Majora's Mask
style but I don't suspect that this is a
mask hiding us from other people instead
I think it's representative of antler
this guy putting on a new Brave face so
he can confront his own depression and
enter the world that scared him for
almost his entire life the moment he
grabs the mask the closed captions read
I wanted to know you in this way for so
long antler's guy has found something
that he can connect with and open up to
back in the pit hands erupt out of
antler's guy and lift him out of the pit
grabbing the complex and ripping it to
shreds the very last thing that we see
in the video is antler's guy still
consumed by the depressing room entity
disappearing and leaving behind only the
outline of his silhouette Morse code
hidden in the closed caption at this
point tells us goodbye and hello in the
video's description reads an ending a
continuation a beginning despite
antler's Guy saying goodbye to the
complex brought on by a lifetime of fear
and incited by the Home lockdowns the
darkness inside of him still lives on in
a small way the depression still follows
him it always will but we're now saying
hello to a new start a new beginning a
chance to co-exist with the darkness to
understand it and most importantly to
handle it in a healthy way and with that
we see the closing of this chapter of
blauvere's story something that I'm
going to call the complex Arc with our
Central character reasserting his voice
and taking steps to pull himself out of
his literal pit of despair now to be
honest there's more to blavare's story
really there is considering the channel
still actively uploading so it's likely
that I'll probably revisit the channel
at some point down the road if you liked
it but for now I just honestly
appreciate how well this story is told
for as horrific as the visuals get the
message is actually real and hopeful
when you live with clinical depression
or anxiety you simply don't defeat it
like you see in so much media it doesn't
just go away vanquished instead you have
to learn to live alongside it in a way
that allows you to continue moving
forward and sometimes you're gonna fail
sometimes you're gonna backslide into
another depressive episode and that's
okay no one is gonna be at their best
every single day and it's okay to reach
out and ask for help when that sort of
thing happens and that's going to be
true for a creepy looking YouTube
protagonist or for you watching at home
dealing with the hard times for yourself
as they say at the end of zoning
ordinance cry out cry out cry cry out
and I bet that you'll find an audience
of people willing to listen able to
relate and eager to help but hey that's
just a theory a film Theory and cuts
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]